foreign
if you identify as a person with
disability
kindly close your eyes
and in your head repeat after me
I am
a person
with disability
thank you
I have bipolar disorder type too
I'm brave to say it now
but it actually took me almost 20 years
to be clinically diagnosed
I had all the symptoms but I did not
seek for medical attention
now I'm giving myself a gift
if I can be real honest I was in denial
and I was ashamed of it
and here's here's another interesting
story
my bipolar diagnosis was actually
prompted by having a chronic illness
I know
and in the Philippines
having a chronic disease can be a reason
for employment discrimination
which I experienced firsthand
and since nobody decided to employ me I
decided to employ myself and started my
company instead to contribute in
building the future of work that lives
now and behind
little did I know
that starting this company thank you
also triggered my healing journey in
embracing my reality as a person living
with disability
worldwide
one in seven people
has a disability
this ability is a reality
that affects us all
it's part of the diversity of Human
Experience
we may be born with it acquired it
through accident or aging or as a result
of trauma and abuse
over one billion people with disability
in the world
hundreds of them
are unemployed especially in developing
countries like the Philippines
their economic inactivity and
unemployment
puts them at a greater risk of
insufficient social protection
making them more vulnerable to extreme
poverty
and impact our global economy trillions
of US Dollars lost in GDP
that's before the pandemic
trillions lost because our society
excludes people like me
for simply getting a job
and it's not just me almost everyone in
my team experience this systemic problem
so we built a virtual school that equips
our students with the skills in the
mindset to work as online service
providers
we have hundreds of graduates in over 60
cities and provinces all over the
Philippines earning an average income
that is 60 percent above the minimum
wage
but we realized that for vocational
programs to be truly sustainable and
effective
technical skills and employment support
are not enough
so we invested in having a resident
psychologist to help our students
process their past experiences
restore human dignity
and embrace the realities
after completing our program
92.6 percent
claimed that they have embraced and they
have understood their disability
so my advice to organizations that are
investing in talents with disability is
to look internally
and identify unconscious bias of our
people around those disabilities
from there
validate and address their fears and
work with your people
to co-create a solution an inclusive
solution together
this is how we can build and sustain
safe space that nurtures healing
and disclosure
disclosure
is the key to the systemic and
intergenerational problem
speaking from my personal experience the
journey to embracing a disability is
painful
it's like coming out of the closet or
sharing
story of sexual assault
forces us to revisit hidden past or
confront in a certain future
it is extremely difficult and it
requires a strong support system
that you and I can build together
so that
hopefully less and lesser people
would no longer suffer in silence
we need to effectively heal
to fight inequality
the only way for us to build to truly
build a world where people can truly
find belonging
is the start
with healing
thank you
[Applause]